she wouldn't do it to herself
intentionally don't make me repeat
myself so what would you have me do
[Music]
right guys straight into it pettiest
things you've done after a breakup
and as per usual
juicy juicy [ __ ] juicy and I'm just
gonna reel them off James I'm just gonna
reel them off say less
moved out whilst he was at work left
sardines everywhere I put chili powder
in all these boxes
that doesn't make sense doesn't it that
doesn't make sense sardines everywhere
everywhere I'm sardines who who oh
sardines are mackerel Remy used to bang
mackerel when we live together he used
to bang out the Macker when we used to
this [ __ ] yeah it's stunk it's
exciting this as well to be first thing
all right say let's put diesel in our
car instead of petrol that's a piss
steak that family that's the rock bro I
promise you it's the ultimate piss take
I've seen I've seen that happen really
you have witnessed us with uh Jay one
day and he accidentally put Petrol in
there on a diesel car oh the cop he
didn't make it 10 meters man it would
rock and he actually drain the whole
team yeah you had to get someone out
live it long
cut up all his teas into crop tops after
I found out he cheated
crop tops
livid all of them yeah all it fam all of
them
do you know how many teas I have all of
them James
[ __ ]
every single one oh he left me for
someone else I caught chlamydia then
[ __ ] him again he passed it on to his
new girlfriend
bro this okay listen to be fair the
titles is this is literally doing what
it says I can't even get mad yeah
because they're openly saying this is
the petty [ __ ] that I'm into yep wow I
went out caught chlamydia and gave it to
him on purpose just so he could give it
to his girl so he has to explain himself
he has to explain to us get dumped and
guess where he's coming next back to me
and I'm gonna close the door in his face
I'm gonna close the door in his face
go fix yourself up no cleanups
poured bleach in all the laundry
detergent and fabric softener
watched all her favorite shows so I
could ruin the endings that's brutal
that is petty all of them all of them to
ruin the endings that would take weeks
it would bro don't say we he's got time
when he Sans he's got time on his hands
jeez also how many shows is she watching
hey I hope to be I'm faithful I watch
shows what on the bounce or multiple bro
right at the moment I'm currently
watching
um obviously on the weekly basis I'm
watching C House of the dragon and rings
of power but an interrupting I'm
watching Better Call Saul I'm watching
um obviously Rick and Morty I'm watching
weekly as well watching better course or
I'm watching the servant I'm watching
um
I'm watching something else that I can't
remember but we've got like six seven
shows and abouts yeah on the bus yeah
I've got a few I've got rings of power
House of the Dragon
Rick and Morty
um
I need to jump back on C and uh what
else am I watching cyberpunk
what's happening all right I haven't I
haven't had times but yeah I'm jumping
back yeah
yeah
I'm jumping back in and jump back in
right Payless thing you've done after a
breakup he suffers with IBS so I put
laxatives in his protein powder it was
the big container
your mom signed her dad up to grinder
wow what are we doing wow what are we
actually doing wow
cut her ponytail off in class that
reminds me
that reminds me of you that reminds me
of you James did you write this yeah
I didn't do it to be paid I did it yeah
I did it because I I was a show-off
I was a [ __ ] childhood show-off you
were trying to be the class Cloud
literally trying to do it and it
backfired if backfired and literally
everyone turned against me oh they they
would have hated you yeah 100 [ __ ] you
know
when I left the flat for the last time I
took the main head of the Hoover
so she's just left with a spout thing
I'll be next I promise you because I
don't even think you can get this you
can't just buy the heads he's a new
Hoover yeah it has to be [ __ ]
[ __ ]
transferred money out of his account
every time he went on a date just so his
card would decline
why do you have still have access yeah
yeah why do you still want to have
access to my accounts transfer access
and talking app it has to be an actual
access to the app and password for
everything
how do you know when I'm going on yeah
and also why do you know why did you
know that are you my PA where are you
yeah because if I'm in Nando's you
clearly have to be in the same number
yeah who's doing up FBI yeah yeah yeah
how are you able to do this consistently
[ __ ] you and your friends all Pricks
yeah because I know you're not just
doing it on your own yeah that's a oh
that's a team effort that is a team
effort it's an OP effort
a friend of mine through glitter all
over his clothes
Glitz do you know how long it's
impossible oh I know exactly how long
it's gonna take to get out I know
exactly how long it takes to get out and
it's gonna take forever [ __ ] even if
we're in the washing machine your
washing machine's [ __ ] oh yeah your
washing machine is [ __ ] even the [ __ ]
that didn't have glitter on it is gonna
get glitter on it
oh it's long long that's long that's at
me crazy
I'll set the whole garment alive yeah
I'd have to burn and start again oh
[ __ ] couldn't stop laughing whilst
trying to break up with him my friend
had to pull me away
I promise you I'll choke her today
I'd have to fight somebody
she can't stop laughing while she's
trying to while you're breaking my heart
you are the love of my life and you you
find this too hilarious that your friend
had to step in and stop it shattered she
had to drag strike you away Jasmine Stop
Jasmine Stop Jazz
he's crying and you're breaking his
heart stop come over here because you're
killing him
you're killing him and she's drapes in
her arm yeah and she's she's resisted
she's resistant to carry on laughing I
have to break up with him yeah yeah he
doesn't get it he's a waste man he's a
joke he's literally a joke and I can't
catch my breath
ah
I'll be there I'll be there with a blade
I'll be there with a blade just thank
you
I'm cutting someone
cutting someone just shaking
[ __ ] me
oh God I dated one of her oldest friends
turns out she was the one we're married
now
that could never be our friendship group
James my reads we're married now and you
expect me to just turn up at the house
lunch whatever for me
that's tough that is tough that's very
tough
put his number on a gay site and labeled
him as desperate for local meets no
plural
desperately
desperate yeah these men ate him up
I couldn't receive one of those calls
James
if I if I'm just whipping and as unknown
number hello hello is this Foo hat from
gay whatever whatever excuse me the new
thing is they they wouldn't even say
true okay what is this food is this food
I'd be like yeah speak no I don't want
to be speaking speaking on a business
thing is this food ad speaking
um
has to be a business thing this
will be a money opportunity it could be
is speaking
oh I've heard um
I've just read your profile and it says
you're um you're about you're local yeah
desperate for local meets and I've got
that wooded
that that we're doing I've got some
heavy meat I've got some heavy meat with
your name on it but I'll look at the
number and say excuse me bro is this
food or not yes it is but I think you've
got the wrong number nah brother you've
seen your bit I've seen your profile
seeing your page yours is the one I want
the sharp sharp and come over I'm
sending you my location now
desperate for local meets James
that's first call I'm changing my number
if I get two more I'm changing yeah oh
if I get one more change of my number
that will scare me I heard you're
looking for Meats plural it's the s that
will send me flew out it was it's the s
that will send me
I heard you're looking for Meats pardon
pardon
that's saying minds and others others
Rags uh Rags I will be terrified I heard
you're looking for meats that would
actually petrify me yeah deep in it that
will actually pass me desperate for
Meats desperate wow wow
stop stop stop stop stop stop stop stop
stop
it immediately immediately
wow right traveled 80 miles and slept
with his online gamer best friend that
he hadn't even met yet
that will cut man up that would cut a
man up because I've seen videos of
online gamer friends meet for the first
time and they it's they really well love
they well up oh my God it's been two
years I can't believe it I've I've
played with people for two years I've
only met them recently yeah yeah I
remember you saying
could never tell me she drove 80 miles
to bang him out of pettiness
and my boy we can't even game together
anymore we can't we literally can't game
together anymore because he can never
tell me this and I can never find out
right and you will find out that's why
she did it she'll make sure you found
out
okay I got a few more oh wow took the
knobs off his cooker so we couldn't even
cook
just a dial thing yeah I'll be [ __ ]
pissed off with that nutted in her milk
how did you get an access to her milk
after she broke up with you how did you
gain intimate access to the glass of
milk after she'd already broken up with
you hey who does I'm thinking it's a
I'm thinking it was probably a situation
where she was dumped they were arguing
in the yard she was done with him she's
like by the time I come back from work
and when you and your [ __ ] God I want
you out of here oh and he just took off
the blue he just took off the blues
nutted in there shook it dipped say less
wow to be fair though I mean that's
disgusting but she's been back in that
facts so she won't even tell the
difference I wouldn't even know facts
and then the best thing he could be like
oh how's that milk taste fine why our
night in there cool so you know yuck but
yeah you're not in my mouth like twice a
week for the last six years so so what's
your actual point cool how did you feel
jacking it into a bottle of milk you're
a joke the table this is this is
this is why this is why you're not in
the house anymore
you know what actually let me ring your
mom now and make sure that she double
locks the milk how about I ring your mom
now and tell her keep the milk Safe Keep
The Milk safe keep the milk in your room
because your son has just admitted
to bashing himself off into bottles of
milk
all right you can't stop nothing because
the call is recorded because you're
you're telling me I just drank nut
unsolicited not
and you think it's a game so that say
let's see how far this game can go
when you're back at your mom's problem
let's see how long you're there
I would shake and cry bro it'll be on a
damage all the cards all the cards
Diamond things that you have to leave
the yard you have to fend for yourself
yeah because you're ruining every
opportunity yeah yeah you can't help
yourself this is why you're single this
you're 28 and you're and you're living
at your mom she's about to dash you out
because you're a joke young man oh oh
that will rock my core
and as soon as I come off this phone
I'm gonna be back in that and it's not
gonna be yours it's gonna be a real
man's night how does that make you how
do you feel little boy how do you
actually feel I promise you now for your
dial tone I can't yeah I can't respond
to that because I know I'm defeated
daltone it'll be a doll tone thing I
would have hung up time ago James I
can't hear all that yeah this is one I
can't hear all that chit chat I can't
I'm sorry I can't yeah my wounds got
enough salt leave me alone leave me
alone
[Applause]
I haven't got time for this anymore I'm
gonna be on the streets next week anyway
so it's ring her now
if I can bring it out I'll use this to
evolve as a human just [ __ ] ring and
stop making threats and ringer
so funny this one is so clutch gave his
number to every dude who asked for mine
in the club
clutch
can you imagine yeah I can that happens
what happened to our boy yeah
he was communicating with next man for
ages on a sweetheart thing
embarrassing embarrassing they play has
she had a back office
back she was playing but then she took
it too far in third year she got she got
bonded she got like weighty I think she
jumped on the pillow Saturn I can't
remember she got big I remember the last
one the last few times I saw I was like
oh
what was what was that Alias again
Big Booty Judy big booty she actually
yeah she was banging it back she was
banging and she didn't have it from
anyone
just always with a girl just chilling
after three years I didn't see a single
guy patting it I couldn't believe it to
the point where she had man playing off
against each other so she was just
giving off male numbers for fun oh you
Jezebel do you know how nervous I would
be to do that
she didn't give a [ __ ] she don't know
nervous to do that that's a breach of
contract that's something you can't just
be giving out numbers like that I'll get
found out immediately
what a smart play
told all her friends all the snakey [ __ ]
she said about them to me I even had
photo evidence oh
Justice is served that's juicy content
that's Justice is served wow all the
sneaky [ __ ] go say [ __ ] bro don't say
[ __ ] girls girls are not for girls
ever [ __ ] it's Joe they hate their
brethrens all of them
they've they've they've got a bad thing
to say about all of their friends 100
percent
the man owed me money so I took his
Nintendo switch
[ __ ] off
last one went to this girl's house he
was cheating on me with beat the [ __ ]
out of him she watched
she be the shout out of him she beat the
[ __ ] out of him and the next time watch
just watching get pumped up he's lost by
his girl he's ex-girl
his ex oh bro just pumped him up and he
just sat there just stopped please stop
stop sorry I'm sorry and then she walks
out and then afterwards so and your new
girl's like wow
Peak yeah leave yeah yeah you actually
have to leave yeah leave leave leave
you're gonna have to yeah literally
leave wow anyway guys that was the um
question of the day prettiest thing
you've done after a breakup wow we that
don't make threats like that do not make
threats at all anytime someone friends
to involve your mum you know it's just
big yeah let's not let's not let's not
let's not
um but anyway guys welcome guys welcome
back episode 225 I believe
um
just real quick before we carry on make
sure you pause the episode right now
head on over to patreon.com forward
slash shits and gigs gain yourself over
now three years worth of content guys
three years worth of content an extra
episode every Thursday and an official
indoctrination into the SMG cult facts
and that's a big deal guys it's a huge
deal three pounded it's all gonna cost
you three pound a month 10p a day run
the pizza sng guys as always guys if
you're watching on YouTube please like
the video if you like the video chirp
sitting in the comments thanks Above All
Else subscribe to the channel facts and
audio listeners give us a nice little
review we really really really
appreciate it five stars is preferable
but if you're feeling stush
as long as it's the true say what you
want to say that being said that's a lie
because last week someone left the one
star review and it broke my heart to
smithereal what did he say or what did
they say was it just a star or no
comment it was a star and a comment what
was the comment it doesn't matter what
the comment was let's just say that it
doesn't matter what the comment was
basically was like these men are
overrated really shut up already really
it's not that funny is this apple I
think so I I read it I was shaking it's
like wow wow why would you do this these
men are overrated sharp already yeah
listen to me Anonymous said it's not
that funny oh I was like bro
bro
so let's try it with the fives yeah yeah
yeah lie to me yeah lie to me make me
feel sex apparently we need to be lied
to make sure yeah please do that guys
because my soul can't take another week
like that that's hilarious but anyway
guys before any further Ado let's get
fuhad to
um
hit us with some fun facts please right
man who donated his mother's body to
Arizona Center for Alzheimer's research
discovers it discovers it was sold to
the US military for six thousand dollars
strapped to a chair and blown up in a
blast test
start that entire sentence again man who
donated his mother's body to an Arizona
Center for Alzheimer's research
discovered it was sold it was sold on to
the US military for six thousand dollars
strapped to a chair and blown up in a
blast test
my eyes widened when I read that caption
So Okay carry on read read the text
Doris 73 died in Hospice Care following
a several year battle with Alzheimer's
despite doctors saying she didn't even
carry the gene for the disease medical
of medical officials fear the disease
may have mutated and hoped to study her
brain after her death but her
neurologist was unable to accept her
remains finally her sons her son settled
on a biological Resource Center in
Maricopa County and signed an agreement
to donate Doris's brain to alzheimer's
research
days later he received a wooden box
labeled with his mother's ashes and an
ID number but was later discovered it
just contained the ashes of just her
hand oh my God the rest of her remains
were sold to the U.S military strapped
into a chair and blown up in Blast tests
to study what happens to humans in cars
whilst hit by IEDs
let me get this straight
so my mum has been suffering for years
with Alzheimer's yes
yes brother and I decide
I can't I wouldn't wish this on my worst
enemy um
I'm doing that research how can I help
with the Alzheimer's research
there's a there's a center that takes in
bodies
and dedicates it to to curing
Alzheimer's yeah they they pick the
brain and they figure out what's going
on yeah
a couple weeks later I give your man a
call and I'm saying sorry this might be
a silly question but I'm just so excited
did you did you find anything in my
mother's brain that might have been
useful to your research
and these May that these might say who
was the name Doris my mum Doris my mum
Doris I donated I don't want anybody to
you not too long yeah like a few weeks
ago I I don't know how long you keep
them cool or chilled or whatever before
you do research like did you manage to
do research did you find anything is
there anything that we can do to help
humanity and be like raw
yeah yeah yeah
turns out
we didn't actually we got an influx this
month and there's only so much we can do
before these things start to erupt yeah
the military were also after bodies
and they donated
six bags for your mom's body
and I don't know what they did with it
I'm not gonna lie to you I don't know
what they did with it
but thank you for your donation because
this the six bags I would be like I've
I've got ashes yeah
I've got ashes delivered Ashes to my
house yeah that wasn't us
pardon
it wasn't us yeah it was us yeah sorry
to reiterate that we didn't do that we
didn't send your Mom's ashes to you I've
I don't know what this ID number is and
I'm not gonna lie to you
there's a there's a video that's
circulating the office it's a bit morbid
but I don't know what your sense of
humor is like but there's a video
circulating I'll send you the link if
you want
you have to send me the link send me the
link cool BBB scent
this is test numbers
three two one
the thing is I don't know what I'm
watching okay I'm getting back what's
this got to do with anything what am I
watching and what's this got to do with
Doris
what's this guy do with Alzheimer's
research I'm so confused I'm so confused
I'm just seeing explosion yeah why are
you sending me as close is that the
right link
is that the right link yes your mum
that's your mum what do you mean that's
fine I'm not gonna lie to you that's
your mother they they're just blowing
[ __ ] up over there
so if you got sent anything I'm not
gonna I don't think you got I don't
think anything you didn't get everything
yeah if you've got anything it
definitely was not the whole ashes how
big is this box
because it's probably like a ring holder
size box
just apparently it was just her hand the
ashes of her hand
James I don't think you'd understand how
many people I'll sue I'll swing everyone
because that is not acceptable I'm suing
everyone also how dare you take the six
grand how dare you take the six grand
how [ __ ] dare you take run me the
Alzheimer's Research Center location
right now because I'm pulling up yeah
I'm pulling up yeah I need when I get
there I want my six bags and interest my
guy six bags interest and the rest of my
mother's ashes yeah how you find it
but this is not why I signed up for yeah
yeah because you man and the military
are taking the piss you think you you
literally think you can do what you want
and I got what the maddest thing about
all of it is how could you accept the
money how how are you shot in bodies my
mom's body how dare you
um the answer he will give is the answer
you gave to us a few weeks ago on the
Pod this is America yeah fam this is
amazing this is America and this is
capitalism what do you mean I can't sell
the demand was higher this is what we
needed fam I do what I want we needed
money and we have bodies to shop why are
you asking questions this is America
last time I checked this is the US of a
and we like money over here communist
[ __ ] cause you're chatting to me like a
communist that's all I'm hearing at your
mouth go back to North Korea my guy oh
my God we're talking unless you're
talking money to me come off my phone
unless you've got bodies okay come off
my phone
because we're set on complaints
the game complaints we're set on
complaints run me some bodies or run me
some money wow or get off my [ __ ]
phone that's the wildest thing I've ever
read yeah that's interesting role play
aside that's the maddest thing I've ever
how did they even let that become common
knowledge like say that's okay that was
in 2019 I read That's that got that
definitely got buried
yeah because I've only that that popped
up on socials a few weeks ago but then I
read that the article was in 2019 then I
had to dig up the article to find out
everything else the only thing I saw was
this heading here and I couldn't find
anything else so I had to dig up and
find I was like oh my goodness
I can insane that's Insanity bro
can't blow up something else that's a
block bodies
I mean nothing's ever going to be a
replica I know but I'm pretty sure if we
just put a mannequin in there yeah it
was like I'm pretty sure they'd die it
will do the same thing yeah because they
use mannequins for car crash tests and
stuff yeah as soon as it blows up
probably about I'm pretty sure
yeah this is not
this is a play play yeah they're testing
bombs out on dead people yes it's insane
that's crazy
that's an understatement that's an
understatement I couldn't believe what I
read
I couldn't believe what I read well of
course that was not fun but it was a
factor today yeah that was a that was I
think a crazy fact crazy ass fact
um you've got a thingy for me you know a
question yeah so
yeah my back's your back's doing bits
but not the bits that everyone says
complaining about it's just cracking
crackhead right
scenario and I'm annoyed because I'll
use like
um I use the United City for example so
let's say let's say me and you went to
the Derby the Manchester Derby the
United sea or let's say we go to the
reverse because obviously you play that
it's had we played a way let's say we go
to reverse United versus C obviously we
we just got tucked in six six three a
few weeks ago we need that we need that
Revenge
so we've gone together we're in we're in
uh we're saying like the Stratford end
or whatever yeah yeah and the game's
going good and we are dominating
possession but you know what I'm like
sometimes when I need to piss I can't
help it I need to go yeah my blood is
doing bits I'm like [ __ ] I'm gonna be
back probably gonna take me three
minutes
dip but within those three minutes
we score a banger I can hear it from the
toilet and I'm vexed yeah I can hear him
and I'm [ __ ] yeah
yeah but whilst I'm away
the whole stadium erupts yeah yeah it
robs every you know you lose your mind
because you don't know what to do yeah
this is the first time you've been in
this situation yeah I don't know what's
going on I don't know what's going on it
rubs and the person in front of you and
the person beside you light up flares I
start waving it around what are you
doing
I'm sitting down
for starters I'm sitting down
I'm sitting the [ __ ] down and I'm
texting you stuff if I'm I'm not
receiving anything yeah
signals ain't doing nothing I'm just
sitting down
scared but not allowing anyone tonight
my scarf is getting tucked in
yeah
I don't want you to know I'm looking for
you
so I'm just like peek in the aisle
peaking that are waiting for you to come
and as soon as you come you'll be like
bro what happened what happened I don't
[ __ ] know I'd feel like a begrudge
like girlfriend yeah yeah I don't
[ __ ] know what happened man are just
waving fire at me
get me out yeah why did you bring me
here this is my way to leave why did you
leave me and why did you bring me here
they're waving fire at people for that
is this what is this how you like to
spend your spare time
[Laughter]
is this what is this what you call fun
oh my God some waste man kicked a ball
in the net and also we're throwing fire
at people
he nearly hit me straight in the [ __ ]
face you can never come back to the
seats and see you sat down in the corner
edged up yeah just waiting for me while
everyone's cheering
bro the dirty nexi will drag you up
celebrate I promise you I am celebrate I
promise you he couldn't he's surprised
yes I hate people forcing me to have fun
I hate family when people score yeah I
know any strangers become family you're
not my boy don't touch Sam grabbing you
and hugging you yeah
grab you by your [ __ ] stock
is celebrate with the rest of us
do you support c yeah that's the first
question do you support C you're on edge
now James you're like where the [ __ ] is
food literally I promise you now I would
pretend to have some kind of learning
disability no you wouldn't
there was too much stimulus for me that
now I wouldn't know what to say James
you wouldn't I wouldn't know what to say
so as soon as he drags me up I will just
go limp but I won't break eye contact
that's where he knows nothing's all
right signs off me up and I'll go limbo
stay staring at him
help me
I know start doing stuff like that yeah
but bad teeth are showing
and you're like oh I love it bro I
promise he wouldn't he'll be gas
he'll be gas goals have been scored
James yeah we're still celebrating fam
can you imagine coming back see some guy
caught me by the Scruff of my scarf and
I'm just putting faces obviously
excuse me excuse me excuse me excuse me
I'll be like yo what happened but I
can't break character I don't know
foreign
and then I'll just give you the recap
I'm not gonna lie I wasn't paying
attention
they were throwing fire at me they were
thrown fire directly at me and I didn't
know what to do and then he and then he
asked me why I'm not celebrating
obviously you know I get facts he put
his hands on me obviously I'm ready to
sweat you have to pick up I'm ready to
swing yeah
but then he accused me of supporting C
and then this guy looked at me this guy
looked at me this way that's what I'm
looking at me and then he picked me up
like this
so my first thing was I had to play
possum
I would have given all the the death top
yeah so I would have given them all I
would have taken their heart out of
their chest and I didn't want to do that
like like seven yeah I don't want to
ruin your day yeah so what I did was I'd
pretended
every time example and then just so we
didn't have to have that okay oh my God
you can never tell me that that's what
took place James you can never tell we'd
have to leave a half time yeah we'd have
to leave at half time because I wouldn't
be able to explain to these man when we
score again I'm celebrating and because
I'm next to you now you've you're
comfortable yeah yeah and you celebrate
with me yeah let's go you're cognitive
you're coherent let's go you man and
then everyone's looking like I thought
you swear down he's something we'd have
to leave yeah we'd have to leave and
I'll be banned for life because of you
foreign
it's a quick one
all right Canadian High School says it's
illegal to criticize and stop trans
teacher who wears huge prosthetic
breasts to school students have been
uploading pictures online and some have
even been and some have even been
skipping classes to avoid the matter
the school board has defended the
teacher and said it's a personal matter
and they need to defend gender rights
what do you think fancy the tease
oh dear
those are out right
necessary let's be honest
they're unnecessary
wow they weren't necessarily big for the
for the audio listeners
they're at least a double G they're here
they're potentially a Double H they're
the biggest they're the biggest
um
biggest meat melons I've ever seen bro
they're unnecessarily big like where all
four gender rights and everything but
there is no need to have no problem he's
that big no brother nipples are just
poking yes and you're meant to be a
teacher yes you are distracted yeah so
confused bro yeah do you know what I
mean but yeah but at the same time if
you're the principal what are you I'm
not sure do not get me wrong the
principle has to do with the smoke he
doesn't want that smoke but as the
teacher
if I'm that teacher I know I don't need
to have my teeth that big I know that
for a fact yeah you do I know that for a
fact yeah I would have yeah I don't know
bro but it's just like [ __ ] I don't know
I think anyone can convince himself of
anything true but it's like he's in his
head in their head they're thinking
women do technically have titties this
big don't get me wrong so if these
weren't my natural titties then what are
you gonna tell me but they're not yeah
but they could be that's the whole point
I know don't get me wrong I know that I
know that and tell me that they're not
again and I'll accuse you of being
transphobic true just say it yeah yeah
true if you're if you're the head
teacher is long yeah the tattoo teacher
doesn't want he doesn't want to smoke
he's in his office he said if he gets a
if I get another comment about this
teacher if one more parent Rings me
about these tears I'm gonna lose my mind
I've got nothing to say about what do
you want me to do
literally what do you want me to do
[ __ ] man they are a distraction oh
they're incredibly distracting she's
trying to do our Woodwork in there
Woodward she's doing up sharp class and
her breasts are just on the woods
they're dangling on the words yeah let's
let's put a bra on a site let's be
reasonable because your nipple is
bursting through the top the sweater
Bros sweat that's thick material yeah
yeah it's a distraction yeah let's
compromise that's all we have that's all
we can do actively compromise and I
think the only person I could compromise
is her yeah she's the only one gonna do
it like what's if I'm the headteacher
what am I gonna say
what am I actually going to say should I
don't want that smoke I oh definitely
don't want that smoke I don't yeah I
don't want that smoke because I would
literally like I would probably talk to
the the parents candidly after I've got
like seven eight calls I've talked to
the parents like with facts and like
what would you have me say literally
what would you have me say well tell her
that cool you tell her that and see how
far we go see where it goes see where it
takes you there's gonna be people
picketing outside and I'm not here for
it I'm just not here I'm just trying to
chill bro I'm a head teacher yeah
reputation I've got a reputation I don't
want to lose my job I don't want this
smoke I'm inclusive yeah I don't want
this smoke and I found I'll literally be
there like it's just tease at the end of
the day if there causing any one
problems it's her it's her facts
[ __ ] she's more effects are better than
you are trust trust me
she wouldn't do this to herself
intentionally but she did she wouldn't
do it to herself intentionally don't
make me repeat myself so what would you
have me do
if you're paying for the reduction
surgery yeah it's all good yeah until
then get off my phone
get off my [ __ ] phone
the repeat sweetened me she didn't do
this it's literally sweetened me what's
up guys let's take a second
to spread awareness spread awareness
with the number one male grooming brand
in the world guys we're talking six
million satisfied men worldwide who
trust your boys and girls over at
manscape that's 12 million balls 12
million nuts Keys happy come on now yes
that can't be wrong smooth that's a
majority vote
jokes so guys whether you're brand new
or ready with manscape you can use the
crown jewel of care for your family
jewels the Platinum package 4.0 so with
this glorious package you can align your
entire hygiene routine all in one swoop
inside the 10 part Platinum package
everything you know and love about the
performance package plus some shower
goodies included to elevate your
grooming game to platinum guys do you
understand that Platinum guys that's a
different level you're not ready for so
guys all you need to do is use the
single-handed most used code
for the second best progress on the
planet the code is sng Sierra November
Golf and you're going to head on over to
manscape.com use that code and collect
yourself 20 off the purchase and free
shipping worldwide guys one more time
for the top that's manscape.com the code
is sng Sierra November golf 20 off and
free shipping let's get back to the
episode like facts
uh interesting one I think I think I saw
that picture I must not read [ __ ]
because the amount of stuff you've
bought to the table yeah that I've just
never
is mad I just don't read stuff
um
speaking of did you see the like what
was it the uh Balenciaga Runway thing
the other day on the mud on the mud I
think I saw that today actually yeah I
only saw that today this morning yes
the thing with um High fashion they
actually take the piss I feel like
them like Balenciaga all these Autumn
winter summer spring whatever Runway
things they do I think as a group every
year they come together and see how can
we take the piss this year yeah yeah
what can we do like did you see them I
think they were Balenciaga as well the
um slippers that were
um water bottles no I did not you didn't
see them no no the the slippers with the
the thing in the middle here where you
in between your your big toe and your
finger you put your finger
um it's a it's a water bottle and the
top of it is the the screw cap like this
the top of it is this and it's a [ __ ]
slipper for what reason well exactly
this is what I'm saying these men have a
these men have a [ __ ]
cult type thing yeah like a [ __ ]
Illuminator for fashion and they see how
they can take the piss out of the the
common public every single year right
this is why I'm happy because we get
invited to do a lot of [ __ ] I'm happy we
don't get invited to do this stuff
I saw one thing the other day where
Bella Hadid was getting their Sprites
right I saw that yeah fam I'm not gonna
lie if I was there because it took a
couple of minutes yeah yeah because it
had you have to spray anything out to
drive yeah
after a minute I'll be like this is the
whole thing is boring because the what's
the ROI on this because the dress looks
[ __ ] who's no one's buying this no
that's let's be honest it's not even for
purchase at this point it's just for the
show yeah it's just literally just for
sure literally for what I don't
understand I don't understand this this
culture I don't understand anything I
actually don't understand the fashion
show called yeah bro I remember I
remember obviously my uh girlfriend back
in the day was a designer and she used
to ask me to go to like her wrong way
stuff
it's the most boring what did it entail
just the same [ __ ] like it's just run
wasting just stuff that they designed
off a theme everyone would have their
own theme okay and they're supposed to
interpret it in fashion yeah it was the
most boring yeah I just don't care man
runways fashion runways don't make sense
unless it's like
um like bikini Victoria Secret acting
because you know you're actually buying
what you see yeah you know but whereas
all these like Balenciaga whatever all
these other ones I see some clothes and
thinking no one is actually going to buy
and wear this no one will ever own this
no one will be looking at this nobody it
looks
disgusting who are we falling bam but
yeah this walking around in mud thing
that's a joke and they're walking around
that they're literally walk around
hunched over like this and I'm like what
are we doing here bro this is not
fashion this is boring and it's [ __ ]
and it's freezing here it would be
challenging yeah it would be freezing
here always in an abandoned spot yeah
yeah yeah guys [ __ ] freezing what are
we actually doing this doesn't make
sense it just does I I hate
certain fashion yeah I watched it many
people when I see them on social like
why are we doing this who am I
explaining because I when I see stuff
like that I always think if I'm a
spectator what am I explaining to
someone when I get home or when I turn
up to work on Monday and they're like
what did you do the weekend I went to
some fashion show thing oh how was it it
was calm it was like like they they'd
sell even if I was into it yeah I was
actually sick like dead set up like they
had this like whole like modern like
muddy track and they just like made it
soaking wet and slippy so all the models
when they're walking around they're like
proper like had to like trait through
the mud and like oh I'm just there look
at that you're talking again looking at
you like sauce
sauce sounds like you're a [ __ ] week
yeah what's the point so why was it
muddy oh just to be different yeah but
why though like why mud like was did it
have something I had nothing to do with
nothing but I was just muddy
and where were you I was like on the
side like it was muddy there too
and you were you were down was this
thing two hours you just watched you
watched people walk in the mud for two
hours what you're telling me is what you
said this was your weekend yeah yeah
this is what you do for fun safe yeah
yeah safe you're a joke you're a joke
and we can't be boys anymore yeah yeah
you're
pathetic actually
it's just yeah the dumbest [ __ ] I've
heard it's just you shouldn't speak to
me like this because this is this this
is the dumbest thing I've heard
um it's long random random random yeah
I'm gonna mind the [ __ ] after this
okay
um I saw the worst movie the other day
with the best cast Okay fam it was an
Amazon original okay Amazon are not
doing themselves any favors with this
[ __ ]
but I couldn't believe what I was
witnessing
before you continue sorry to cut you off
I saw a trailer for a movie coming out
called Amsterdam star studded casts
where swear to [ __ ] I'll check it out
you have to check it out yeah you have
to check it out started I'll check it
out but yeah continue I watched two [ __ ]
movies actually
on the same day both on Amazon same day
no across two days if you watch back to
back
I'd have to jump
because what am I doing choosing these
movies two [ __ ] movies the first ship
movie
um that wasn't the star-stated one was
Beast the Idris Elba movie I saw that I
rented it yeah I spent 15 pounds
sterling on this dog [ __ ] movie you're
pissed I I watched out of my um sisters
last month and they just streamed it if
I was like if I'm gonna have to do a
fire stick thing or satin because I paid
15 hard-earned pounds for this dog [ __ ]
yeah it was AV dog [ __ ] it was basically
[ __ ] Jaws it was Jaws in Africa yeah
yeah is what it was yours on acid in
Africa yeah they exploded a car and the
thing got a couple of burns on it yeah
yeah what we do what are we on about it
would have blown up into literal pieces
yeah yeah
dumbest movie
dumbest movie terrible acting and no
offense it takes his American accent no
offense I hate your accent brother your
American accent's terrible your accent
stop it stop it stop it you've gone from
being on the wild man didn't know for
years that you were English no one knew
for years your English this accent was
God awful that's coupled with the
American accent he did in the office has
been the worst two accidents I've ever
seen you do Idris yeah
I'm not gonna lie to you disappointed
lock it up have you seen he's done he's
done a music video not too long ago with
his misses in it I don't want to see
that bro it's like Idris
why what's all this venturing you're
doing yeah yeah yeah fam get off the
decks for five minutes five minutes and
work on your craft Focus yeah literally
Idris participate Focus [ __ ]
participate because you're an actor yeah
you're a big man you're an actor these
men are talking about you doing up James
Bond brother these times you're doing up
Jaws in Africa with a terrible American
accent Focus man terrible absolutely the
whole thing was joked even that no
offense the acting wasn't great either
it's a good thing you thought it wasn't
in it his real daughter yeah
did her a favor or a favor did her a
secret little favor it's not a good
movie Man Beast is terrible sorry guys
it's absolutely terrible
um the second terrible movie I watched
was a movie called
something like
don't worry you can't get far on foot
I've never heard of that right there
listen to who's in this movie please
don't worry you can't get far on foot he
can't get far on foot okay
Joaquin Phoenix
okay Jonah Hill okay Jack Black okay and
the other guy can't remember her name
she's the
um she's in bear movies she's in
I'm pretty sure do you remember the Tom
Cruise movie where he keeps going back
in time every time he dies or something
like that
they're like fighting aliens and [ __ ]
and every time
like that yeah yeah I know exactly the
movie you're talking about and the miss
the girl in the camera I can't remember
who she is though yeah yeah I remember
the movie but I can't remember what the
girls look like anyway huh okay
Joaquin Phoenix Jack Black and Jonah
Hill that started I was scrolling
through Amazon I see that Amazon
original I see all these faces on the
thing I was like holy [ __ ] let's go I've
never even heard of this movie yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah we've got winners on here
Academy Award winners let's go I'll
press play immediately I was like these
men are playing with me yeah yeah
when did it come out I did I didn't
bother to check okay I didn't even
finish if you had oh I got three
quarters of it got tired turned off
never went back to it oh swear worst
[ __ ] movie ever swear it's so [ __ ]
what's the premise
I was begging they were telling me it's
a true story because I was thinking
there's nothing that can be this [ __ ]
that's not based on true events
there's got nothing to lean on but maybe
it is but I didn't say it it's based on
an alcoholic guy
who gets in a car accident and is
paralyzed basically from like the chest
down so his arms move but like a little
bit okay who's who plays him Joaquin
Phoenix bro why convenience is the lead
okay
um and yeah basically he he is this is
it's his thing about kind of getting
over alcoholism and what it's like to be
a quadriplegic the whole thing was just
dead for halting was done Jonah Hill
played a fantastic gay man I'm not gonna
lie Jonah Hill did wonderfully Jack
Black was in it for four and a half
seconds oh he probably made 10 mil facts
for a little little Cameo it was
pointless the whole film was pointless
I've never felt so betrayed oh that's it
I'm not the biggest click bait I've ever
experienced I've not seen a bad movie
like that in a while bro what um
no no apart from
no I don't think I've seen a film that
bad in a while that was terrible yeah
especially within like a star study
class that was worse than Beast yeah
especially yeah
it's not the best dog [ __ ] I didn't I
don't it didn't expect much
Sunday night little a little bit of
action little home entertainment yeah
yeah yeah yeah let me just feel
something
before we get into our Monday morning
it's the worst experience
that's the [ __ ] worst experience ah
sorry G so real quick before we get onto
your thread I
um have a I've realized who the smartest
man in the world is
liver King
okay the thing I don't know much about
the brother but I only see his face on
um a snap because you know they've got
snap stories on the thingy so I see I
always see his figures always there he's
wow
and he's lying to he's obviously on
steroids of course obviously he denies
it foreign
so basically liver King if you don't
know
super famous guy at the minute who
basically just promotes this very like
tribal old-school lifestyle lifestyle he
eats a lot of [ __ ] raw organs bro he
eats a lot of raw organs actually never
seen him eat one I've seen him eat a lot
I've not seen him fam one time I saw him
bam one time yeah one time he took it
too fast he took it too far okay he got
a fish
and squeezed out their eggs out of the
pump into his mouth I've never seen
anything more disgraceful in my life I
was like all right bro that's just too
much the thing is when you said fish I
didn't even know what you were yes he
got the pump and was just like
bad caviar in his mouth
oh bro it was like
bro that yeah there's there's levels to
it and that's just not necessary put it
in a bowl and Spoon it must never throw
up oh bro his gag reflex is mad he's had
a time in his life that's all I know
he's had some stuff but anyway the
reason he's so smart
well the reason the con
what's that fluff it's gone how long has
that been there I'd literally just
noticed it I hope just now and mothers I
just noticed that you have fluff in your
hair a few weeks ago and I couldn't see
it because on that side okay the
comments were blowing up that comes with
blows like how the [ __ ] did he not tell
free that he's got fluff in his hair the
whole episode
um anyway so
yeah liver King yeah he's a little
market ingenious because the basically
he's on a ridiculous amount of gear
obviously and um
but no one can defeat he obviously
denies being on gear but no one can
definitively prove that he's not on gear
okay because no one is willing to do
what he does yeah to prove it
yeah facts that makes sense the only way
people can prove that he's not on gear
is to eat how he eats and live how he
live for multiple years yeah and then be
like look at me he's on gear bro he's on
gear bro because I've done it for three
years and I'm being eaten liver for
years and I'm throwing it
I'm throwing up I mean it has got all
four times I stay in hospital I've got
health concerns this is not a
sustainable way of life he's in jail
regularly lying to us he's injecting
testosterone and eating roast dinners
like the rest of us
liver King is [ __ ] yeah facts but no
one's willing to do it yeah I never
thought about that he stays eating liver
and balls bro Jesus raw balls why is why
man I don't know why because he just
says it's good for you but like it's not
it can't be I mean
if he's living he's obviously living
this like Primal life and if you
actually look at the animal kingdom
that's how they live and
if you look he's an alpha and let's say
he's like if you relate him to like a a
lion a leopard or a tumor whatever
that's how these men eat it is that's
how these men eat it's how they eat and
that's what I'm saying bro I'm sure
there's a lot of validity to the stuff
he's saying I'm also sure he injects a
lot he's he's he's because he's too
blocked out he's Wham and shredded and
he's in his 40s food yeah he's two
blocked out not to be on site it's Wham
and Shred he's on his is in his 40s yeah
it doesn't make sense he makes money as
well I'm not surprised I'm not surprised
he makes money I'm not surprised I
haven't listened to it but I saw a
thumbnail of him on a podcast I've
listened to him on a few podcasts
there's another one that come out the
title was how he makes a hundred million
a year
excuse me how liver King makes 100
million a year
I know his supplements do bits wow
his own supplements that he sells he
owns his own supplement brand that he
sells probably just powdered liver and
stuff
powdered liver
I think that's jokes he makes millions
wow when did he start off do you know I
don't know actually no okay go get me um
so basically he actually started off as
a normal business guy okay was he always
into German and bodybuilding and stuff I
think so yeah yeah he was um he's always
been into bodybuilding that kind of
stuff he actually owned like a uh like a
dental surgery and some other businesses
and stuff like yeah cake okay yeah cake
no Fame just cake okay
um and then he adopted this Primal
lifestyle he said because his kids both
of his kids were suffering with like
breathing issues and they were on all
these medications and all these
anti-allergens and all this stuff and he
basically was like doing research and
was like this is no way to live your
life like my kids can't breathe my kids
are little kids they can't breathe
they're on drugs okay there are multiple
drugs it's not normal okay so you
completely flip the way they live their
life they now they live this Primal life
and like it's healed his kids and kids
eat Primal as well his whole family does
it bro not just him he calls his wife
liver Queen he never uses her name and
it's infuriating oh wow he always calls
that liver Queen I want to punch him
when I see him do it it infuriates
what's his what's her actual name I
don't know no one knows it's called a
liver Queen oh my goodness
um [ __ ] and then yeah so
he lives like that even at night they
turn off all the electricity in their
house [ __ ] stay away from like all
the waves and them tingling oh wow he
keeps all the electricity off in his
house
um he lives on this massive Ranch and
stuff I'm not surprised he's got cake
bro so
um yeah and then basically he started
doing content about living like this way
and just eating raw liver on Tick Tock
and [ __ ] and now he's got that yeah he's
famous famous now he's crazy famous I
promise you now I how many uses he got
two use I think he's got two boys yeah
two boys I can never be one of his sons
and try and invite one of my friends
over to my yard yeah it's not because
what are we actually eating like what
kind of what am I telling my friends
that I eat for dinner oh Raw Liver bro
because my dad's the liver King they're
not coming over yeah and they're like
what does your dad do for work my dad's
the liver King party yeah he's like raw
[ __ ]
and it just makes bad it just makes
money and we live on this [ __ ] off
massive Ranch yeah I don't know what
else he does but I don't know what he
does I just see him eat liver and run
and stuff run and take videos yeah he's
always shooting always shooting stuff um
but yeah his kids don't go school his
kids are homeschooled
makes sense it does make sense it makes
perfect sense yeah it makes perfect
sense perfect yeah he's like a he's like
a marketing genius for that so I'm on
like a big like I'm obsessed with
business stuff at the minute I know you
are oh bro I'm a balls deep gang I can't
uh
my obsession with certain things is
concerning when I'm into something I I'm
I'm [ __ ] obsessed with it for like
years that's how it was with Jiu Jitsu
and if I went if I went back to Jujitsu
it would happen again I need to stop
like when I get into something I'm fully
sleeping to it so right now the content
that I'm digesting because they're like
at the very peak of their like uh
influence and like Fame there's a guy
called Alex homozy who is like a very
successful business person who does a
lot of content uh and is very
transparent about the way he does
business and sales and makes money in
his Concepts on money and his concepts
of all these other things okay
um being sure stuff Mr Beast is doing a
runner podcast at the minute is this
over the last week I've probably
listened to like nine hours of Mr Beast
talking gang I've just been binging and
stuff gang that's so crazy because I was
like I said before we were Nando's
earlier you mentioned Mr Beast and I was
like I was actually thinking about on
the drive down here I want to watch I
want to watch more of his stuff bro his
thing is as well is I actually you only
really realized this the other day is
like um someone made a it was actually
that Alex was a guy made a really really
powerful comment that was like oh this
is actually facts that people don't like
appreciate like when people say like
it's basically um talking about like the
concept of being like the greatest of
all time so if someone wants to be the
greatest of all time a lot of people
like they they have a competitive aspect
and they
um
they compare themselves to the people
before them so their job is to be like
Oh I'm gonna be better than this person
I'm gonna be better that person you can
look at your growth and be like Oh by
the time
I'm his age or the bottom of the at this
point or he who's been doing YouTube for
four years by time I've been doing
YouTube for four years bro I'm gonna be
like flying past him yeah yeah yeah
um makes sense people forget that the
only reason you are able to do that is
because of that person so like Mr Beast
like famously says that he he when he
was coming up he's he was talking he
made like four friends or whatever was a
group of like four of them and they
would speak for hours every day
only about YouTube for a thousand days
and once he's done that he took all the
information he learned and implemented
into his videos and now he just speaks
openly about all the stuff that he
learned and how to make good stuff so
like it makes sense that if someone is
he's the best YouTuber on the planet
right so if he is willing to share all
of his information why would you not
listen to all of it implement it
yourself and then Fast Track yeah your
success yeah and it's not because you're
better than Mr Beast is because without
him you would have to do what the [ __ ]
he did right so it's like people like
people I feel like some people don't
even like digest like the same like you
know they're saying like pay they paved
the way yeah they lay the foundation
literal the literal definition of Paving
the way is doing the hard work so that
the people after you don't have to do it
so when there's people at the top of
their game like I'm obsessed with like
people who are like smashing it in their
right respective areas because it's like
well I'll just listen to everything you
say because you've already done it and
then when when it's my turn like I can
just implement it and I'll just get
there faster
um and I I used to struggle not struggle
but I used to
um
do the same thing which I'm embarrassed
of now is that when we were starting off
I used to look at people that'd be doing
it and I'd be like oh they've got this
many subs and they've been doing for
this year they're like four years
Whatever by the time we've been doing it
for four years we'll have way more subs
than that it's like yeah but the four
years that they've been doing they
didn't have anyone they didn't have
themselves to look at and be like this
yeah yeah and same thing was now that
we've been doing it for three years and
we do us a certain we'll do the way that
we do things it's done a certain way now
yeah people look at us and be like bro
they've got this many followers they've
got this much I'm just going to do what
they do and then they'll do it and
they'll be looking at us and be like bro
they've got five million followers now
bro by the time I've been doing it for
three years I promise you're gonna have
more than five million but it's like
when we started doing it I didn't have
anyone else to copy facts I had to do it
the shitty way and learn for [ __ ]
years how to do it properly no one else
whereas if I had someone who was if I if
there was a podcaster at the time that
was similar to us who was doing this
kind of content on social media then I
could have looked at them at the on day
one and be like bro these men have this
many followers let's just do what they
do yeah and then edit in a similar way
and understand what the storytelling and
understand the the things that do well
and
um we speak openly about it anyway so
it's like they could just listen to us
and copy us and then bang but we didn't
have that so I had to do it for [ __ ]
years to figure out how to do it and now
we've got there there's going to be
people who belong after us that will go
way further than us way faster but
that's the point yeah true Innovation
that is literally the point it's not
even competition that's the [ __ ]
point of doing it you pave the way so
that other people can just walk it
um so yeah
I've been digesting Alex almost for guys
who care really really interesting
um Mr Beast obviously if you're
interested in content Creation in any
facet yeah listen to what this guy has
to say because he's like learned about
it for years and is willing to share
live again I find interesting because
he's just like a weird guy who makes a
[ __ ] ton of money he's a guy who's put
himself in a very very very unique
marketing position very neat and has
capitalized it incredibly well yeah
um and I just find that fascinating um
I'm sure there's other people that Ali
Abdul is an interesting one as well I've
listened to his stuff for years he's a
good one
um he's not I wouldn't say he's at the
height he's not like the Pinnacle of
what he does but he is um very open
about like money in the way he does
money and what is it's a nice like
insight to see you someone is very very
transparent yeah super transparent which
is helpful for someone who's a few steps
ahead of you
um but yeah bro I just find all that
stuff so fascinating okay
so fascinating I'm balls deep okay God I
can't get enough of it I can't get
[ __ ] enough of it anyway you've got a
thread for us today yeah so I'm gonna
wrap this episode up with a thread I
found on Twitter I think I found it the
other day actually and it's actually
pretty jokes so the thread is
a short one
what's the scariest and very British
forward Horror Story you can think of
you'll get the context when I start
reading okay this one says first one
everyone get into pairs
bro in primary secondary school times
all right everyone get into pass my
heart's B in Bravo
and the thing is as well
you have one chance literally if you
pick go to pick someone and they say
sorry I've got a partner by the time
you've turned around everyone's got a
partner and you're just there with the
Lonesome kid with the glasses in the
back you're back or it's an odd number
you have to oh you can pair with a
teacher today yeah you're with your oh
don't worry James you're with me today
you're with me to embarrass sin because
you are the scapegoat yeah doing art for
the class you're doing up demos yeah you
are you don't even know what you're
doing you are the class Escape [ __ ] oh
everyone get into pairs that is
terrifying that's terrifying all right
so now you know there's just another
thing
can I call you
your lip quivered
your lip quivered James I've never every
time a female has sent me that message
can I call you no kiss nothing
can I call you
palpitations it's unnecessary just Bell
me don't even don't just bail me don't
anticipate all these things just Bell me
I ain't got time for that
let's all introduce ourselves
oh my God who had say your name and say
a faster fascinating fact about you [ __ ]
you bro
that's interesting this is what this is
the interesting I hate it my name is
James and I hate it
imagine
I would love to be a fly on the wall if
that being said Rags bro that would be
hilarious content my name is Jefferson I
hate it here
this one triggered me rail replacement
bus service
brother my secondary school days oh I
can imagine bus service rail
replacements
rail replacement in in Essex dagenham
size oh okay is the best taste because
the district line is on the weekend if
there's Road replacement on any line on
the weekend 100 is the District 100 and
that's the only line that my mom's hands
because obviously there's loads but
there's multiple lines wherever you stop
is only District brother and his only
district for another four stops so you
gotta even uh bro
that used to be me that used to be me
when um when when I used to travel home
on weekends and I needed to get back to
Cove northampton's a Cove we're
literally talking like 45 minutes on the
train 40 minutes on the train yeah yeah
light yeah well I'd Rock up to
Northampton station
big sign yeah rare replacement buses and
they're doing all the stops oh yeah Rags
they are they used to drive from from
Northampton to Long buckby which is like
20 minutes from there to rugby and a
young Nanny as well and then you'd have
to get off at one of them and then get
the train took off I knew bro I weren't
getting back to cough till midnight
I used to hate it if you had
a joke all right another one is this
seat taken on a public transport thing
I always love to keep my bag yeah my
back has to stay bag or something or I'm
just edge up on the side like this
is this seat taken fam yeah obviously
yes obviously I don't want you to I
don't want anyone yeah it's taken by my
personal space
move yes basically no
bro so frustrating oh God
still on for tonight oh fam
that's
that's the worst one to send oh Rags
Rags rags and you don't get a reply for
hours
for tonight
canceled and I'm embarrassed embarrassed
that I even had to ask because we've not
spoken all day bro do you know what the
worst one is
I'm gonna be sick oh I'm actually gonna
be sick you message them still good for
tonight yeah question mark you don't get
she she reads it you know she's reading
you see you come online yeah yeah yeah
comes offline yeah Double Take she comes
offline you don't hear from her for an
hour and then you get a voice note back
she's made plans she's tried to get
voice note back
and you're like you know it's an
explanation too she's justifying her
lies
and she sent a voice so it sounds more
excuse me perhaps she's like oh I'm so
sorry you're never gonna believe it babe
it's always hey babe you're never gonna
believe shut your filthy little mouse
just tell me you hate me yeah it's
easier it's easy off
[ __ ] you know
I would literally rather than reply like
yuck no synonym for tonight yeah no no
I'll run out oh I swear James I'm not
gonna lie to you I couldn't receive that
I'm not gonna lie to you run me that
voice though because I couldn't receive
that yuck no
I couldn't look at you man the same
again I couldn't look at you man the
same oh God imagine yuck no
God no
James uh because that's in a group chat
now yeah right tracks [ __ ]
arrive early for networking
that's my worst nightmare never receive
that message and I pray I never do I
arrived early for networking for
networking fam I remember this is this
is this is how London to me is bizarre
yeah bizarre I remember one time I went
to oh this is one of those days where I
had to do the stand up and say something
interesting
I went to an open day not an open day
um an assessment day okay basically a
massive group interview okay [ __ ]
hell okay all day like oh God in London
travel down all day in London for this
job thing oh God it was the worst day of
my life but anyway I got talking to some
girl
uh before we went in did you have your
name badge and everything like that yeah
hi I'm James
[ __ ] [ __ ] bro I am James
nah nah
I literally wanted to kill myself the
only thing that kept me there was I was
too embarrassed to just walk out oh
facts I know I know
otherwise I would have been gone I know
um anyway before it starts talking just
go and then she was just asking about
like what this or that and she was
struggling to get a job and all that she
was like yeah I've been going to
networking parties and I was like pardon
she was like yeah I just got to these
Network bars they're super helpful I was
thinking first of all they're obviously
not because you're here you're here
you're in the same place you may have
been doing them plural oh God and she
was like yeah they're naturally not too
bad you go there you network you and I
fam I remember saying to her stop saying
network just stop I hate that word stop
saying network you're pissing me off
get there early to network a networking
party yo that's that's dead what what
are we doing we're just meeting
strangers meeting strangers and talking
exchange what do you do all day for what
reason it's a network
ing part because if I need a job filled
if I'm a boss yeah and I need a job
filled yeah
why am I going to a network party
I'll just hire someone facts I'm not
like the only people who are networking
parties are people who need to network
who don't have a network so we're all
just bad people without networks so this
network party might pay off in seven
years when everyone else has succeeded
and then we want to use these
connections we've made yeah but at the
moment at this Foundation we're all
losers yeah so why am I here that says
she's been to several networking parties
working they help a lot they're a really
big help they're not because you're here
with me
dead worst day of my life this one for
me it's gone to penalties it's gone to
penalties ah
stress
as per my email oh oh
bro
as per my email fight me car park
literally because that's a threat yeah
yeah that's a threat or a dismissal
I'm not even reading the rest car park
car parking 10. call Park in the
subjects
nobody nobody car park explanation
explanation explanation car park she
would be rattled he or she Sam what do
you mean I'm not replying I'm just
saying car park again
jokes oh God the last one will you marry
me
Jesus Christ scariest
fear for the people who ask that
question and not know what the answer
might be they're they're in the wrong
relationship yeah they're in their own
relationships they're in their own world
and they are willing to risk everything
to take it
everything to take into the next level
oh God damn it that was a really good
one yeah that has one
everyone get into pears nightmare Hearts
palpitations James I you know when I
used to [ __ ] hate that in uni because
it was always me you and REM
it was always three of us yeah and I
remember there's a few times we I I just
said I'm not good I'm not leaving
I remember I remember I used to just say
well well we've got a three oh yeah
because it was also Dems and Saucy they
were together they were together and
then and it was always Gemma and that
Vicky yes yes yes wolf prayer and cattle
yeah
Oh my days yeah and it was um what was
the brother that killed someone pardon
the Blackberry what's his name pardon
the Black Bridge remember the Blackberry
in our class he never came back because
he stabbed someone because they fought
his cousin or something like that do you
remember his name the Blackberry in our
class bro I think I remember his face
but God knows I feel like his name began
with C God knows I don't remember his
name I do was he African yeah yeah I
remember his face one all over yes I
remember yeah it was probably Kenyon or
something I remember his face but his
name James I'm pretty sure he stabbed
someone oh my god um why you've got a
memory on you yeah yeah
and he was always alone so I was like
it's either I'm I'm staying in my three
or I'm pairing up with him and I promise
you it's not that I promise you it's not
gonna lie
we're a three
that's just it and yeah and eventually
they'd have to learn they just know that
we because I'm not doing up pairs with
some random potential future murderer
yeah I'm not going to do it thanks
Richard
oh there was another brother called
James in our class as well I remember
the rugby breath yeah
James yes
who's the James I don't I can't remember
that was Adam I remember Adam no no 100
100 it was never record James I'm pretty
sure Adam used to snort alcohol off bars
oh my God yes he did when everyone
spilled a drink on the bar I remember he
would snort up and he laughed and he
laughed his wet face just laughing I was
like yeah we were a bit different we
were in class with delinquents yeah
rugby Liam
he looked a Hagrid
let's trap this [ __ ] up yeah sorry guys
we're going down something memory left
not even relevant to you man but yeah
anyway guys thank you so much for today
as always guys head on over to
patreon.com forward slash [ __ ] and gigs
of Vibes get yourself some extra
episodes and uh as always guys see you
next time
[Music]
foreign